Herkese iyi akşamlar
Sesim geliyor Sanırım
ben bugün sizlere Anadolu'da ve dünyada
yaklaşık 10.000 yıllık Geçmiş olan Kadim
bir gıdadan peynirden bahsedeceğim Ben
Anadolu'yu karış gezen Kadim bu
reçeteleri kayıt altına alan
fotoğraflayan ve geleneksel üretimle
bilimi birleştiren aslında bir gıda
mühendisiyim
Benim Hikayem Rize'nin Hemşin ilçesinde
babara yaylasında başladı Emine teyze
ile buluşmam da başladı Emine teyze ile
Biz tesadüf eseri tamamıyla bir tatil
esnasında tanıştık ve ben ikinci kez
bedene yaylasına gittim ne için kolot
peyniri yapmak için
[Müzik]
Aslında sesi ve şivesi var ama burada
çıkmamış O kadar güzel bir kadın ki
Yaşına rağmen yani bedene izin vermiyor
ama beyni ruhu o kadar güzel ki
beraber ürettik Şimdi ben tabi bir daha
mühendisliği olarak Yaylaya giderken
yanımda termometre pH metre mi götürdüm
Emine teyze ile şu gördüğünüz Kazan ki
bu kazanda biliyorsunuz köylerde
sobaların üzerinde Hem çamaşır
kaynatılır hem peynir yapılır aynı Kazan
olmasa bile aynı türevler kullanır ne
kullanıyor Başka tahta Kaşıklar ahşap
yapılar kullanılıyor Aslında Emine teyze
şimdi sütü koydu Ocağı sobaya koyuyordu
Daha doğrusu ısınmaya başladı lütfen
termometre ile elimde bekliyorum sütünü
ısınmasını acaba kaç derecede
mayalayacağız diye Emine teyze şu an bu
arada 88 yaşında Ama tabii ki bu yaşı
torunuyla irtibattayım okul çağına
gelirken kiminle çıkmış neredeyse
Dolayısıyla yaş oldukça fazla
bile gözlerine bakarak bana dedi ki evet
tamam mayala ben ölçtüm tam bir mayalama
sıcaktı
mıhlamanın olmazsa olmazı
sündüreceğiz dedim ki Emine teyze oldu
mu acaba bu dedi ki bana olmuştur dedi
gözüyle
ölçtüm gerçekten yaptığımız şeyin
Aslında bilimsel bir açıklaması vardı
işte benim peynirle serüvenime peynir
Aşkım Emine teyzeyle başladı
bir diğer güzel kadın emeksel kadın
Zübeyde Hanım Zübeyde Hanım tam bir
Yörük kadını Ayvacık çınarpınar köyünde
yaşıyor bir koyun sürüsü var bu
fotoğrafta hayvanları köyünde beraber
gülerken torunu sırtında uyuya kalmıştı
ama hayvanları Biz tabi başıboş
bırakamıyorsunuz geri çevireceğiz akşam
üretim için ben böyle anlık çekmiştim
benim için çok kıymetli ve özel bir
fotoğraf Yani bir anda torunu bir anda
hayvanlar bir anda benle ilgileniyor ve
sarım saatini bekliyoruz
Onunla ne yaptık Onunla da bu bölgede
çok özel ve önemli bir peyniri Tepme
peyniri yaptık Tepme ismi nereden
geliyor biliyor musunuz
peyniri bildiğiniz testiye tepiyorsunuz
tık direkt sokuyorsunuz tepiyorsunuz
buradan geliyor ismi tamamen yerelde
bunu da verilmiş Yörükler bu ismi vermiş
Yörüklerin o bölgede beslemiş olduğum
çok güzel koyun sürüleri var Tamamen
yerelde yapılan üretimler Bunlar yerli
hayvan ırkları Baharda peynirlerini
yapar Yörükler salamuraya basarlar
ardından Eylül ayında Eylül ayında Bu
peynir ufalar içine çörek otu koyar ve
Bu gördüğünüz hırsız testilere basarlar
daha sonra ağzına asma yaprağı üstüne
bildiğimiz çamur Yani evet ocaktan
aldığınız bir kuğu çamuru alıp bulayıp
üstüne kapatıyorsunuz ağzına da bir bez
bağlayın ters çevirip toprak altına
gömüyorsunuz
burada olduğu gibi
[Müzik]
yaklaşık Bu peynir Eylül ayında
koyuyorsunuz ve 4-5 ay toprak altında
kalıyor neden Nisan'da mayaladığımız
sütü Eylül ayında koyuyoruz neden başka
bir aileyiz hemen söyleyeyim Bu testi
Öncelikle sırsız bir testi olmalı
ardından ardından içine güzel bir
sonbaharın Yağmur suyunu ve kar suyunu
çekmeli Yağmur ve kar suyu geçtiği zaman
toprak altına ardından testi diye
testiden de peynire mikroorganizmalar o
kadar güzel çalışıyor ki inanılmaz tat
bir arama oluşturuyor sizin için
bir diğer güzel yer iki tane Emektar
kadın Hozat Tuncer Tunceli inanılmaz
güzel bir coğrafya onlarla birlikte de
benim kayıt altına aldığımda incelediğim
çok önemli bir
aşama var Tuluk dediğimiz şey
hayvanların derilerin o bölgede
peynirlere basıyorlar bunu incelemek
için ben oraya gittim asıl en önemli ve
güzel şey bu anlatacağım iki tane Kadim
reçete var burada bu iki tane güzel
yemekler kadının çok değerli eğitimli 3
tane kızı var ve bu reçeteleri yapmak
için bölgede çabalıyorlar bir şekilde
bana ulaştılar ve biz bunları kayıt
altına aldık ve devam ettirmek için de
şu an hala çalışmaları devam ediyoruz
şimdi
buradaki tane peynir var bir tanesi
tulum peyniri keçi tulum peyniri bir
tanesi de pajdo pajdo süzme yoğurt
kıvamında inanılmaz damaksatlı tam bir
yapı Gerçekten biz bu peyniri önce neden
koyun deresine basıyoruz Çünkü koyun
derisi içinde böyle üstünde gözenekleri
çok fazla olan nefes alıp verebilen bir
deridir peyniri buna koyduğunuz zaman
çok rahat olgunlaşıyor tatlı araması
gelişiyor devamında saklamak ve satışa
sunmak istiyorsanız kötü derisine
koyuyorsunuz Çünkü keçi derisi daha sık
kıl yapısına sahip Dolayısıyla
Havaalanı alışverişini engelleyerek uzun
dönemde ürünün raf ömrünü arttıran bir
yapıda Bu gördüğünüz derilere Az önce
gösterdiğim derim
yoğurdu koyuyorsunuz bir miktar tuz
ekliyorsunuz bu Tabii Yayla da oluyor
şehirde olmuyor ben denedim olmuyor
hiçbir peynir anlattığım peynir şehirde
olmuyor başka bir bölgede olmuyor
tamamen o bölgeye ait hayvanların
sütünden o bölgeye ait sütlerden
yapılıyor
taşları yoğurdu koyuyorsunuz içerisine
bir miktar tuz ilave ediyorsunuz bir
yere asıyorsunuz yaylada Ara ara tuzunu
tekrarlayabilirsiniz yeni yoğurt
katabilirsiniz içerisine deriden yavaş
yavaş süzülerek çok lezzetli bir yoğurt
çıkıyor ortaya ardından deriyi kullanmak
istiyorsanız bildiğiniz ayrana
yatırıyorsunuz bile ne koyuyorsunuz
üzerine ayran Evet daha sonra
kurutuyorsunuz deriyi bir baltanın
sapıyla ya da bir herhangi bir sopayla
açıp beyazlatıp tekrar kullanıyorsunuz
Evet bu benim en çalışmaktan keyif aldım
ve destek verdiğim
bölge Hakkari
burada çok güzel bir kadın Kooperatifi
var çiçeklerin özü kadın Kooperatifi o
kadar güzel bir coğrafyada yaşıyorlar ki
koyunlarından kendi koyunlarından otlu
peyniri yapıyorlar Yine toprak altına
gömüyorlar gördüğünüz bu arkadaki yer
bildiğiniz mağara mağara da üretim
yapıyorlar ve süzme çalıştıkları
aparatları görüyor musunuz eski
buzdolapları var ya onun arkasındaki
siyah teller Çünkü bir aparat alet
ekipman yok ama geleneksel hala oralarda
üretilmeye devam ediyor
bu peynire özel kılan şeylerden bir
tanesi şirden
ne demek Bunu kısaca açıklayayım
Kuzuların oğlakların kursağına annesi
sütünden başka hiçbir şey girmemiş ot
yememiş hayvanların midesi bu midesi bu
midenin içerisinde peyniri çok güzel
mayalayan Pepsi ve kümesin denilen
enzimler var en mükemmel hali o midede
bulunuyor bu mide şu gördüğünüz elimizde
tuttuğumuz Yapı Evet bu videoyu
kurutuyorsunuz temizliyorsunuz o
aşamalardan sonra bu bölgede halen
yapılan unutulmaya yüz tutmuş bir önemli
bir reçetedir bu mideyle birlikte
gördüğünüz İncir taneleri Kavun karpuz
çekirdekleri o bölgeye ait endemik
kodları bir beze koyuyorsunuz Daha sonra
bir bidona yerleştiriyorsunuz videonun
da önemi şu; içerisinde peynir altı suyu
ve baharın ilk yağmur suları var
Evet Bahar'ın ilk yağmur suları bu Yapı
içerisinde yaklaşık 1-2 ay
olgunlaştıktan sonra bunu Peynir
yapımında kullanıyorlar
Eğer bu peynirleri bir gün tatmış
olsanız gerçekten peynir yemediğinizde
anlarsınız O kadar aromatik ve o kadar
güzel ki endüstriyelle hiçbir alakası
yok Bir diğer yaptıkları bilim şimdi
koyun sütünün kuru maddesi çok yüksektir
çok koyu kıvamdır Biz genelde şehirde
inek sütü kullandığımız için eğer
yabancıysanız
şöyle aktarayım koyun sütü çok koyu
kıvamlı ve ısıyı harlı verdiğiniz zaman
besin değeri düşer hemen altı yanar O
gördüğünüz altı yanık tabaka vardır ya
tencerelerde görürsünüz o bir protein
tabakasıdır aslında bütün besin değeri
düşer orada ne yapıyorlar biliyor
musunuz koyun sütünü tezekle ısıtıyorlar
Çünkü tezek çok önemli bir yakacaktır
ısıyı o kadar yavaş o kadar güzel verir
ki koyun sütü hiçbir şekilde zararı
uğramaz
sütlerden yoğurtlar yapıyorlar zaten
orada yaz ilkbahar çok az kısa sürüyor 2
ay 3 aydır
Şimdi yoğurt yemek için bu sütleri
ısıtıp çömleklerde yoğurt mayalayıp
Toprak altına gömüyorlar ve 4-5 ay sonra
onu kış yoğurdu olarak tüketiyorlar
şu
fotoğrafınıza dikkat çekmek istiyorum şu
oturuşa bakıyor şu anatomiye bakın Yani
tamamen sağım için
yapılmış bir şey bir hareket bunu her
kadın yapamaz ben denedim olmadı Evet
olmadı süt soğan kadına da o bölgede
Berivan
Evet bir diğer Kadim reçete ünlü Hanım
eşi Mustafa Bey ile Havran'da yaşıyor
Balıkesir'de
onlar da havran'ın otlu kirli peynirini
yapıyorlar şu gördüğünüz arkada Az önce
şırdandan bahsettik onlar da şirden'i
üretiyorlar Ve arkada gördüğünüz manzara
var ya o Manzarada yaşıyorlar şirdene
onlar tuzlu suya basıyorlar küçük küçük
dilimliyorlar içlerin nohut biraz çörek
otu bakın çörek otu her yerde geçiyor
peynirde korumada vesaire Anadolu'da çok
Kadim kullanılan bir gıda daha sonra
bunu peynirlerinde kullanıyorlar biz
onlarla ne yaptık Havran otlu kelle
peynirini üreterek bunu kayıt altına
aldık Bakın şu estetiğe
peynirin taze formu ilk yaptığınız hal
İkincisi ise salamuradan çıkmış hali
Yani yaklaşık 3 ay sonraki hali bu
fotoğrafı ilk Görenler bana şey söylüyor
Fransa'daki bir çalışman mı Rokfor mu
yani içerisindeki Kürt zannediyorlar bu
dışını görmeseniz sadece içini görseniz
genelde küf zannediliyor Hayır bu
havran'a özgü Sadece o bölgede olan
sadece o yerde yetişen bir lanet türü
yine denedik şehirde olmadı şehirdeki
nanelerle olmuyor
Evet
Burası da
Ece köy
Ece köy Biga Çanakkale'de Biga kadın
kooperatifine bağlı süt ürünleri üreten
tamamen Kadim reçeteleri devam ettiren
bir kadın Kooperatifi
bireysel çalışmalarım Ben Anadolu'da
yürütürken Anadolu'da ve dünyada bir
yandan da bir STK görevim var Anadolu'da
çok Etkin çalışan ve kadınların ekonomik
olarak güçlenmesine katkıda bulunan bir
vakıfla kadın emeğin değerlendirme Vakfı
ile çalışıyorum
şuna Vakfı yıllar önce o bölgede süt
ürünleri üreten ve hayvan sahibi
kadınlara mikro mandıralar kurdu yani
leğenlerde ürettikleri ürünleri artık
teleme teknelerinde böyle tencerede
ürettiklerini 50 litrelik
pastörizatörlerde üretir hale geldiler
ama Kadim reçetelerinden Asla ödün
vermediler Ben de onlara bu üretim ve
Arge döneminde eşlik ettim
herkes peyniri
kendi sarılığıdır
sütüne peynire vermiştir Çerkez peyniri
Biga'ya yöresine yerleşen Herkesler
kafkaslardan bunun mayasını gelirken
yanlarında getirmişler koyun sütünden
üretmeye başlamışlar Evet zamanla koyun
azalmaya başlamış ineklere diğerleriyle
devam etmişler daha sonra biz ne yaptık
Anadolu'da o bölgede yaşayan yaklaşık 10
tane Çerkez kadınıyla bir araya gelip bu
peynirin reçetesini tekrar oluşturduk şu
an ortak birleşirse ile bu ürünü
üretmekteler Bu arada yanındaki sepette
geleneksel üretimde kullanılan
Normalde Çerkezlerin kullandığı bir
sepet türü bu sepeti
kurutmada geçmişte kullanıyorlarmış Biga
ve yöresinde Eğer bu sepeti kapıda
görürseniz mutlaka ya kapıda ya da bir
ağaçta asılı olurmuş o evde Çerkezlerin
yaşadığını bilirmişsiniz Hatta bu peynir
o kadar sert ve kuru bir forma geliyor
ki bacalarda kurutuyorlar kafesi sistem
yapıyorlar bunlar için hatta saklamak
için buğday ambarına koyuyorlar çünkü
hiçbir haşere buğdayın içine girmez
üstünden atlar bir o zamanlar buğdayı
çok sahip oldukları için hiçbir
ambalajlama paketleme de korumak için
ürünün içerisine koyuyorlar
bu bölgede yaptığım çalışmalardan bir
tanesi Bu gördüğünüz
bitkiler peynire katılan bitkiler
denediğimiz arge'de denediğimiz bitkiler
özellikle güve otu
güve otun hikayesini anlatmak istiyorum
kadın Kooperatifinde Eğitim alan
kadınlarından kadınlardan bir tanesi
büyük bir keçi sürüsüne sahip ve Biga ve
yöresinde
otlatıyor Bu bir gün boltu getirdi bana
dedi ki hocam keçiler sürekli bunu yiyor
ve biz bunu evlerde kullanıyoruz
yemeklerde kullanıyoruz peynir de
Deneyelim mi Fikriye geldi
keçi yiyorsa bir şeyi mutlaka onda bir
hikmet vardır keçiler çok gurmedir kötü
bir şey asla Yemezler çok özür diliyorum
dışkıların üzerine bile oturmazlar öyle
temize Gurme hayvanlardır sonra biz bu
bitkiyi peynire kattık ne yaptı biliyor
musunuz tat aromasını geliştirmekle
beraber ürünün raf ömrünü arttırdı Siz
ürüne dışarıdan küf veriyorsunuz peynir
yine küflenmiyor o kadar Kadim ve güzel
bir bitki dünyada 5 bölgede yetişiyor ve
en önemli en güzel
formu bir gör ve kaz dağlarında
yetişiyor bir diğeri de Bulgarların
zamanında getirdi çipura otu denilen
kekik Killer familyasından Bir ot o da
tat arama verdiği gibi alternatif tıpta
o bölgede kullanılan bir yapıp peynire
inanılmaz bir lezzet katıyor ve raf
ömrünü arttırıyor
Evet benim favori peynirlerimden bir
tanesi dil ile Obruk peyniri
Obruk peyniri coğrafi işaretle dünyanın
5 peyniri arasına girmiş bir peynirdir
Karaman'da divrede üretiliyor gördüğünüz
hanımefendi Sultan Hanım gülle
muhtarının annesi Evet çok tatlı bir
kadın onunla birlikte bu Reçeteyi
oluşturduk ve kayıt altına aldık Bana
dediler ki bir gün Hocam bu peynir güzel
de içinde ne var bilmiyoruz ne yapalım
getirdim İstanbul'da laboratuvarlarda
detaylı besin değer analizleri yaptırdım
ve Ne gördüm biliyor musunuz normal
Karbonhidrat yağ proteinin dışında
içinde öyle bir ameliyat var ki kilo
İnsan beynine damarlarını besleyen
sedefendi salgılatan ruh sağlığına iyi
gelen unutkanlığa iyi gelen bir Amine
ve bu peynir dışarıda gördü dışında
gördüğünüz kırmızı yapılar küfler
tamamen mağaradan gelen
küfler Normalde Az önce anlattım deriyi
tuluğu anlattım sizlere dışı biraz daha
krem formda bu kırmızı küf mağaradan
geliyor Siz bu peynirlerinizi yaptıktan
sonra koyun sütten yaptığınız peynirleri
deriye basıyorsunuz daha sonra 250-300
metre derinliğindeki mağaralara
koyuyorsunuz Yaklaşık 5 derece sıcaklık
%99-%70 orada bu kırmızı küfler oluşuyor
bir diğer önemli şey Aysel Ayten Hanım
tesadüfen karşılaştık oğlumun işte
Otelde kaldım Akşam
koyunlarını Sadık sabahtan mutfağa
girdim dedim ki Mutlaka bir şey
yapacaktır sabah sütüyle bir yedim ne
göreyim tereyağı yapıyor ama ya eliyle
topluyor koyun sütün üzerinde biriken
bir yağ tabakası var
yine bilim yapıyor Çünkü gerçek bir yağ
gerçek bir tereyağı İnsan vücudunda
İnsan vücudunda hemen erimeye başlar
evlerinizde bunu test etmek isterseniz
gerçek bir tereyağı yediğinizden emin
olmak istiyorsanız avucunuza koyun yağı
hızlı bir şekilde erimeye başlaması
lazım bir kaşık ya da bir aparat
kullansa bu kadar kolay toplayamaz yağı
Evet Anadolu ile beraber
dünyada da özellikle İtalya Güney İtalya
tam geleneksel üretimin yapıldığı bir
bölge Benim için orada da çalışmalarım
devam ediyor bakın orada da hala peyniri
tekneleri ahşap bakır kazananlar ahşap
aparatlar kullanılıyor Bu fotoğraf çok
taze bir fotoğraf Yaklaşık 3 hafta önce
çekilmiş bir fotoğraf telefonda
sağ taraftaki şirden zaten anlattım
birkaç kez sol taraftaki de benim
yaptırmış olduğum bir doğum Normalde
köyleri geziyorum ve herkesin doğum
yaptırdığını görüyorum şaşkınlıkla
izliyorum ama ilk defa kendim bir doğum
yaptırdım ve çok kısmetliydim ikiz
oldular hayatımda yaşadığım en önemli
şeylerden bir tanesiydi beni etkileyen
sahnelerden biriydi
Bu da yine geçtiğimiz haftalarda
İtalya'da kalebrea Bölgesi'nde
ikinci jenerasyon bir mandıradaki
çalışmam dünyada en çok satılan
peynirlerden bir tanesi yenen
peynirlerden bir tanesi mozzarelladır
endüstriyel üretim Burada da devam
ediyor Lakin Bakın şu gördüğünüz peyniri
bu şekilde şekillendirdiğim Yapı
temsileme teknesi birinci jenerasyondan
kalan 80 yıllık bir tekne oralarda
Avrupa'da insanlar gelenekselden de
vazgeçmiyor endüstriyeye cevap verirken
Bunun dışında son olarak söyleyeceğim
ben Anadolu'da ve dünyada geleneksel'i
üretmeye çalışmaya devam edeceğim
bunları kayıt altına alacağım özellikle
Anadolu'da bunları ulaşamayan kadınlara
bunları taşıyıp hepsine bir alan
açacağım Çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]